When you love someone,
you love them,
not only despite their fragile it,
but also because of it wouldn't be who
they were if they weren't fragile and
limited in their particular way.
When you have a sick kid,
it's like,
oh my God,
how can the world be constituted so that
a child can unfairly suffered in this
map?
You can't have them being vulnerable and
cute and interesting and small and
needing care,
but striving to develop and grow without
them also being prone to pain and
destruction and vulnerability,
and then what do you do?
Teach them to be strong.
That's what you do.
You don't get rid of the vulnerability.
It teach them to be strong.
You don't protect your children.
In fact,
you do.
You do the opposite.
You expose them to the world as much as
you possibly can and you make them
strong.
That's the best antidote to their
vulnerability.
The first noble truth of Buddhism life
is suffering.
This is true and it's worse than that
because it's suffering contaminated by
malevolence and so that's very
pessimistic,
but the optimistic part is that you are
so damn tough.
You can actually know that we deal with
that,
oh,
well that's a horrible situation,
but it turns out that I'm armed for the
task.
That's.
That's a great thing for people.
I think the fact that we're armed for
the task is even more true than the fact
that life is catastrophe contaminated by
malevolence were stronger than things
are terrible.
Do believe it's the case because I've
watched people do very difficult things
like people who work in palliative care
wards,
so all they're ever dealing with his
pain and death,
right,
and they can do it and get up in the
morning.
They go to work and they take care of
those people.
They lose people on a weekly basis and
yet they can do it,
and what that shows is that if you turn
around and you confront the suffering
voluntarily who find out that you are
way tougher than you think.
It's not that life is better than you
think.
Life isn't as harsh as you think.
It might even be worse,
but you are way tougher than you think.
If you turn around and confronted,
it's a very good thing to know and it's
not naive optimism.
It's a very different thing.
It's like,
no,
things are terrible.
They are brutal and you are so damn
tough.
You can't believe it.